what is 12 squared quite a few of us
would know that it's 144 but in this
video we will look at a super quick way
to square a number the first thing we
need to do is look at the number that is
being squared it's 12 the numbers we
will be looking at squaring in this
session will be close to some power of
10 by powers of 10 I mean 10 100 1000
and so on so while squaring such numbers
we first choose a base which is close to
the number that is being squared and the
base will be some power of 10 here 12 is
close to 10 so let 10 be the base here
once the base is decided we find the
difference between the number and the
base that will be 12 minus 10 which
equals to this number here is really
important it's the difference between
the number and the base we will soon see
why but understand the first few steps
really well we choose the base which is
close to the number and then we found
the difference between the base and the
number after these steps we make a
partition on the Left we write the sum
of the number and the difference that
will be 12 plus 2 sum of the number and
the difference and on the right we
simply square the difference it will be
2 squared 12 plus 2 is 14 and 2 squared
is 4 we have the answer
12 squared is 144 let's review it again
we found the base and then found the
difference between the number and the
base after making a partition on the
Left we wrote the sum of the number and
the difference and on the right we wrote
the square of the difference and that
gave us the answer but we should be
careful about just one thing here the
number of digits we should write on the
right hand side should be equal to the
number of zeros in the base here as
there is just one zero in the base we
write just one digit on the right if
there were two zeros on the base we
would have had two
for as zero for why don't you try one
now try using the same technique to find
14 squared here we can choose the base
as 10 as 14 is pretty close to it the
next step is to find the difference
between the number and the base that
will be 14 minus 10 which equals 4 after
this we make a partition on the left we
write the sum of the number and the
difference that will be 14 plus 4 and on
the right we'll square the difference so
we write 4 squared 14 plus 4 is 18 and 4
squared is 16 so the answer is 1816 this
is a very common mistake that students
make when they use this technique
don't forget what had told you the
number of digits on the right will be
equal to the number of zeros on the base
as there is just one zero in the base we
will have just one digit on the right so
14 plus 4 is 18 and 4 squared is 16 as
just one digit is allowed on the right
we carry the 1 over and write 6 here 6 8
plus 1 is 9 + 1 that's the answer 14
squared is 196 the takeaway here was
that we wrote the unit's digit 6 here
and carried the 1 over as just one digit
was allowed here's the last example
which I want you to try 98 squared the
number 98 is close to 100 so we choose
the base as 100 once the base is chosen
we subtract a number from the base to
find the difference that will be 98-100
and that will be minus 2 we have the
base we have the difference now we make
the partition on the left we have the
sum of the number and the difference 98
plus minus 2 can be written as 98 minus
2
and on the right we have the square of
the difference that will be minus
2-squared will the answer be 964 don't
forget the number of digits on the right
will be equal to the number of zeros in
the base as there are two zeros in the
base there will be two digits on the
right so 98 minus 2 is 96 and minus 2
squared will be written as 0 for 98
squared is equal to 9604 remember the
steps base difference between the number
and the base partition sum of the number
and this difference on the left and the
square of the difference on the right in
the next part of the session we will
solve for squares of larger numbers
which are close to the power of 10
you